just to find Progressive and then at the
same time you said you weren't a fan of
the woke left make that distinction okay
great question so number one mainstream
Progressive believes in all of Bernie
Sanders economic policies So Paid Family
Leave higher minimum wage Medicare for
all end of gerrymandering end of bribery
in politics skate corporate cash
etc those are all incredibly popular
positions two-thirds of the country
wants all of that okay but you mentioned
AOC I wouldn't advise AOC to run some of
our positions are too radical left and
the world's going to end so she she said
the world's gonna end so why even run if
the world's gonna end well that's a
different question that's about climate
change we could come back to that but
but like she like he she went on air on
CNN we're talking about abortion 70 of
the country agrees with us they should
be legal in the first two trimesters
right and she starts referring to
mothers as birthing persons I'm like
what are you doing
you know how many people want to refer
to moms as birthing persons two percent
yeah and your girl Anna caught some heat
over that yeah and so we drew the line
and said no we're not going to call moms
people with uteruses and they're like
you're doing that out of nowhere you're
attacking us no brothers and sisters if
you're going to run against buying
you're going to run to try to win the
country over don't go to the two percent
position go to the 70 position so many
Progressive policies are sitting right
there at 70 percent run on those but she
can't help herself so she's going to run
on things like birthing person and I
mean look some on the left now believe
in abolishing prisons
I'm sorry guys I love you and I do
they're on our Network and they're good
people and they mean well but that's not
so nobody believes in that right so do
they understand the fallacy of their
argument do they truly understand how
they're ridiculous they sound no they
don't I mean look they had this debate
on a show with the right winger and a
left-winger Brianna Joey gray was on the
left and she's making the argument
against uh she's making an argument for
abolishing prisons and the right-wing
guy who I don't agree with normally at
all he's like yes but if I hit somebody
in their face with a brick I go to
prison right and she's like no I'm like
that
what was the reason for that because
prisons are awful that's true prisons
are awful that's why we should reform
them like for example my whole life
everybody's like oh yeah you get raped
in prison I'm like why is that oh yeah
like we should fix that comes with the
sentence right do you know that here's
your jumpsuit and then some lube you
know the last time I checked the stats
more men get raped than women because of
Prisons that doesn't insane game because
they they moved away from soaps to gel
yeah
so can you pull up so they're not wrong
that prisons are awful and we should
reform them and and Norway is the better
model even though it drives me crazy
because I kind of like Vengeance a
little bit but Norway it brings down
recidivism so much more than we do but
but they're saying no we get rid of them
and eventually we have Kumbaya we had
them on the show we asked a thousand
times and then what and they talk about
like restorative justice oh you can do
restorative justice you can for a lot of
people right that took the wrong turn
but some folks just are born different
this guy's murdered four people what do
you want to do with this guy yeah I'm
not letting him out by the way by the
way if you ask the same exact folks on
the left yeah hey should Trump go to
prison they're like yes wait a minute I
thought we were abolishing prisons yeah
okay why is Trump going to prison why is
why color criminal what do they say to
that they want Trump to go to
alchemistics like they want to put him
on an island us with Sean Connery yeah
yeah and look I don't want to make them
out to be like a huge part of the left
they're tiny percentage of the left
right
we got 30 minutes left and I got a few
more stories I want to go through this
was good very helpful did you have one
other you said you had one other thing
yeah one other thing is look guys I I'm
curious what I'm genuinely super curious
what you guys think look I've kind of
given up on Congress uh I tried the
inside strategy I tried to help Bernie
uh I formed Justice Democrats we've got
11 folks in Congress now but they just
won't do it they won't pass any laws
that Americans care about and by the way
the culture wars makes everybody rich
and so the right wing loves the culture
wars the left wing loves the culture
wars the country hates the culture wars
and the country gets nothing because of
the culture wars so uh what I want to do
is ask right-wing shows left-wing shows
and every show in the middle can we
unite on any policy because everybody
says that the country is divided
hopelessly divided I know that isn't
true we are hopelessly divided on some
issues race gender Etc but we are not
divided on economic issues so I mean
maybe this is the best show to come on
ask for this maybe this is the worst
show you I don't know you tell me but
Paid Family Leave pulls at 84 three
quarters of Republican voters say yes I
want moms to have a break after they
deliver their children okay so can we
push from the outside can the right wing
and left wing go yeah we agree on this
forget everything else we hate each
other on everything else but we agree on
this give moms a break okay give them 12
weeks off after they deliver that's Pro
mom pro-conservative pro-life right it's
also pro-progressive we all agree can we
push from the outside and say God damn
it you do your stupid Hunter Biden
investigations or your brilliant Hunter
Biden investigations whatever you want
but as you're doing all of that can you
just give us one bill paid family leave
moms get 12 weeks off in Estonia they
get 82 weeks off in Sweden they get 64
weeks off in Japan they get a whole year
off why because they want to encourage
it people having kids they want to
encourage families that's why three
quarters of Republicans agree now why
don't they do it if 84 of Americans want
it because they're all corporatists the
corporate Republicans and the corporate
Democrats take money from corporations
the only people in the country who don't
want moms to get 12 weeks off are
corporate interest and they bribe all of
our politicians and that's why I've
given up on the inside track but I bet
that if all the shows on the outside or
enough of them said yes Paid Family
Leave God damn it give them at least 12
weeks off right
that maybe we could get a past where's
this poll the 84 percent do you know any
poll you can look up any poll on paid
family I just typed in right now see if
you can find a robot but what is the
current uh time
zero moms have to go back to the
assembly line the day after they deliver
that's something that's in America well
I didn't P I mean I'm not trying to be
funny but people the judge had a baby
with his guy exactly you got three
months didn't he get three months yeah
you know why because 24 of Americans get
paid family only 24 everybody else in
the world 100 okay who are the 24 all
rich people oh all Executives all
government officials Etc
so Executives get 12 weeks off that's
standard fare okay so as a company like
we give 12 weeks off but in the
beginning the standard was you give it
to the executives and we said no we're
gonna give it to everybody and people
are like whoa you're gonna give it to
everybody that's crazy because it's in
the corporate mindset that you don't do
that for the average American so average
Americans we all agree we all agree the
media is lying we don't disagree about
everything let's go do this together
let's go past paid family leave if we
breathe down there next and you guys
read on their necks they're gonna notice
me so if you like this clip and you want
to watch another one click right here
and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]